are you struggling to make content that
rocks well i did too and i made this
crazy video without knocking myself into
a tree with this crazy background on how
to actually fix this so i was actually
asked to speak at a seven figure
entrepreneur event it was a paid event
and one of the questions that came up uh
that i was told the answer that i had
was uh impactful for many of them was
around the concept of content and if you
don't know who i am my name's austria
mozilla own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies that's about 85
million a year and i have nothing to
sell you all right so uh this is an
excerpt of the video of me answering
that question if you're struggling to
make content enjoy this
what is the best way to create content
i know it's not specific enough oh i'm
not the best diaper so like i really
love what you guys are putting out right
now seriously straight fire um both of
you guys like
kudos um and you know maybe i'm just
stuck in kind of like my head but i'm
having difficulty like just putting it
out there like i know i could talk for
hours on any topic fitness business life
whatever and i do with my friends
consistently all day
then i get in front and i'm like what
the [ __ ] do i make excuse the language
um i'm like what do i make how do i
structure this how should i say this and
god ah that's what happens so
i've done it and i'm not sure if it's
just like i've done it so much now that
i i also i'm looking more so on for my
end to like work with people who want to
perform better who don't just want to
lose a little bit away who like really
want to be you know
legit better version of themselves you
know i know that's probably used
consistently across the fitness industry
but um like that's genuinely what i want
to help you with i want them to help
like hit that potential because i that's
what i like doing for myself um so
that's my like question there i guess
like i probably struggle more with
content creation than alex hasn't in a
while now so maybe i could talk about
that before because like alex creates
better content than me like i think that
he's been doing this for like [ __ ]
eight years i started like six months
ago and every time i'm like dude i look
like [ __ ] i feel like [ __ ] this is
terrible it's awful you know that's all
i say like i'm like look everyone hates
me like for sure they're bad but alex
says like i observe alex and a lot of
times like i'll literally take notes on
his videos and deconstruct what he's
doing because i think he's really good
at it right and i'll watch him while
he's creating and i've sat there when
he's come up with videos and there's two
things that i've identified that helped
me a lot which is one alex is really
sure about who he's talking to and he
knows it every time he's talking okay
that's the first thing so then when i'm
talking like who am i talking to and a
lot of the times the things that
probably inspire you prince are like
about the clients
so like a lot of times
when i just made like a really good
piece of content the other day because i
got off the phone with a company that we
have a and we're invested with and i was
like i had this epiphany on the phone
with them and i was ranting and i just
thought and went and made the content
and i see alex did it all the time he's
like i got it i got to go make it now
and i think it's really hard because
like i never believed alex in the
beginning where he's like no you just
gotta like catch it when you get it you
gotta go like make like six videos and i
was like dude no i like organize my
whole schedule i set time side i need to
film now but it's almost like a
self-inflicted pressure when you like
set that time sometimes and then you
just start getting your head you're like
i must make five pieces of content right
now and i'm not so i must [ __ ] suck
right
and instead it's just like you're just
not in the zone because creativity isn't
like constraints
so it's like you have to catch like when
the creativity's there when you're less
constrained and you're more free flowing
i think that's when things come most
naturally that plus knowing who you're
talking to
and then the other thing i'll say is um
i don't think that you should make
content on anything you don't want to
make content on which i've heard alex
say a million times when because he's i
asked him for advice on it a lot right
now that's why i feel like i'm i can say
this to you because i've been asking
alex a lot of questions and he's like
dude don't talk about anything you don't
want to talk about and sometimes make
the content that you want to make even
though you don't you're not sure it will
hit like there are certain videos that
i've made like on how to run a great
meeting and my youtube guy is like dude
nobody gives a [ __ ] and i was like i
don't care i need to make this video
like for me i know it's [ __ ]
important right and so i think it's
allowing yourself to just do whatever
the [ __ ] you want kind of makes it
better
and you hear alex's videos he's like
dude i'm not making this for you guys
and he's serious he's making it for
himself and so i think um
you know i i observe that and i'm like
that's how i feel like i mean alex you
know i'm just speaking for you but i
feel like that's how you've been able to
continue to make content as your wife
who watches you and sees you do it all
the time it's like you do you make a lot
for yourself you make a lot for the
people that you know who they are and
who you're talking to
and if you don't feel like making it you
don't do it i make videos for really
only one of two reasons one is because i
want to document a thought process so
that means it's for me or it's fresh off
of some sort of conversation i had with
you know a client employee or one of the
you know the business owners that we're
invested in and so i'm basically making
it for them and i just make it anonymous
and usually i'm very passionate about
the topic which is why i want to make
the video um but i heard this from grant
uh cardone
and uh when we were talking about his
content strategy
and he said you just gotta make [ __ ] and
you have to assume no one will see it
like the assumption is zero and then
just make all your content from that
perspective because the thing is is like
you guys have heard me say this but like
the work works on you more than you work
on it and doing the content is a long
play it's a super super long play and
unfortunately it takes a long time to be
good for two reasons one is that you
actually have to be good at doing it
which you will get better with
repetition and the second is that people
don't care about you until you've done
something like if i tweeted the same
[ __ ] elon musk tweets no one would care
but it's elon musk and so he's the
richest man in the world and if he just
does a poop emoji it gets shared you
know 500 000 times it's not because the
message it's because of the messenger
and the messenger is a big part of the
message part of the reason that content
doesn't hit even if it's really
wonderful content is because people are
like why should i listen to you and if
you don't have a genuine answer for that
then they won't have one either my views
on content have shifted dramatically
over time but i think the reason that
the content that i have now hits is
because like we've made a lot of [ __ ]
money and people are like wow that's
impressive when i started i wasn't as
big on content because
honestly it was like i just don't think
anyone was going to give a [ __ ] and they
probably weren't and so like i'm just
adding those as quick caveats but for
you specifically
what you don't want to do is start
talking like everyone else
right don't talk about when they should
time their carbs don't talk about how
they should be
splitting up like no one cares if you're
talking to your specific avatar then the
types of things that you should be
making should be relevant to that
specific avatar which often times will
be different than what everyone else is
talking about
and it'll be it'll be unique to you
that's kind of my my my big picture
stuff
on on consecration but i put two notes
in there which is like do it when it's
fresh and do it when you feel emotions
those have been like kind of two of my
my mainstays for making content i i
often feel um the way that what you've
talked about is like i haven't done [ __ ]
yet like i i like why you're right like
so i'm almost in that same point with
business and i feel with being online um
the difference between being in gym and
being online is you know online is the
same i think working with online coach
is the same thing is like why should i
work with you
you know what have you done right so
that's kind of my next follow-up
question it's actually second phase is
it cool if i said real quick what is the
best way to generate those type of leads
when
you know you haven't done [ __ ] like i
hadn't
done [ __ ] well the thing is is okay this
is a really i think this is a good
caveat for everyone
everyone here has done [ __ ] but not
everyone here has done [ __ ] that they
want to talk about
so this is the classic example of the
dudes who were talking about how to make
passive income online make 10 grand a
month and they've never [ __ ] made 10
grand a month and they're talking about
how to manipulate the stock market and
their stock portfolio is 100 grand like
who gives a [ __ ] right like you're not
warren buffett right but the thing is is
that you are an expert at some things
and you should just stick to only
talking about that stuff
if if the source of your content this is
like i'm gonna this is [ __ ] big if
the source of your content
is other people's content
don't make it
what makes content interesting is the
unique anecdotes that you have
experienced and gone through which add
value
and this is kind of a big issue in
general with the like the content
creation world is that
people are making content because it's
easy to make content and because they
have an alternative agenda the content
that hits is content that is made for
its own sake as an as with the intention
of adding to the body of knowledge on a
specific subject matter
and so if you have been working with
clients and you're like
this is something that's worked really
well for the guys that i have i only
have seven clients but like this has
worked really well i hope it works well
for you
you say that you have domain expertise
in those seven clients and no one can
question you there now if you start
talking about science and you don't
[ __ ] know anything about science but
you read it on mike israel or you read
it from dr cashy
you're not dr cashy and so of course
like it's not going to sound as good
from you and if i'm going to try and
listen to that i'm listening to dr k
and so it's like we have to know what we
are experts in like i'm only a little
bit talking about investment stuff now
but for the vast majority of stuff i
talk about i talk about sales i talk
about acquisition and it's because we've
built it for six different companies and
we've exited six different companies you
know i mean in the last you know 10
years right and different types of
companies right software we've exited
brick and mortar we've done services
like we've done different types of
things and so i can speak about that
with authority and people know that and
i have a story to back that up when you
just talk about content
no one cares and so tie it to stuff that
you actually know and one of my last
rules of content is if you don't have
anything worth saying don't say it
and i know this is probably a little
contrary to other people's stuff but i
don't really give a [ __ ] like if it's
not worth saying don't say it because in
my opinion i'd rather have someone not
consume [ __ ] from me than consume
something and then decide to never
listen to me ever again because it's a
waste of their time that's mine that's
my content
drop so that piece that i just said that
probably was a piece of content that we
probably clipped later
all right that helped very much so thank
you guys so much
and if you have specific this is a side
note for tactics right if you have a
spec if you have a handful of specific
beliefs that people are trying to
overcome rather than necessarily
addressing the belief you can make it
relevant by saying hey if you're
struggling with this my client karen and
then all of a sudden you have domain
authority because you're now introducing
a real story rather than just saying
here's how you overcome overeating no
i have two clients i won't i'll just use
sarah and kate as the names but these
are real clients that are on my roster
right now and this is the issue they
were struggling with this is how we
dealt with it and i'm going to say one
more piece on this content thing because
i think it's it's also like i've learned
a lot of things over this is that you
don't want to make
declarative statements
you want to say this is the way it is
it's very easy to contradict that
instead it's this is my two sense this
is how i see the world and what i have
experienced i might not know [ __ ] but
i'm sharing what has been valuable to me
and my clients and when you say it from
that perspective one the intention is
pure and two no one can [ __ ] with you on
that because you're you're not saying
this is you're not saying this fact
you're saying this is this is how i see
it
and if things change i'll tell you how i
think they've changed that's really dope
and it's also super unique because like
it's your experience right so it has to
be wildly different than everyone else's
or at least somewhat yeah step one do
stuff and then step two talk about the
stuff you did right the problem is that
people start talking about stuff they
haven't done
and then that's where they get in
trouble because all they do is they read
someone else's article on passive income
and then they do a worse diluted version
with less authority